I knew that I could figure out how to
put something inside of a bag of
M&M's and reeal it in real time without
anybody noticing and I thought what
could I do with that let's just find out
yeah yeah and that's where it started to
become a JZ so this interaction with
this guy Jamal when he came up he says
so you can steal something from me and I
said I I don't really know what was your
name he goes Jamal I said how do you
spell that Jamal and he said J I said
could you write that down for me and he
pulls out his pen he goes to write it
down and his pen wasn't working and as
we've heard before yeah and I said and
up to this point my stuttering the break
of my speech the break of my sight lines
with him has been very low status break
of your sight lines meaning eye contact
yeah I didn't keep straight eye contact
with him very much I asked him about his
suit that's really fancy it was all
those status and then everything just
changed then it's this thing I said
would this help y out Jamal and it's
straight eye contact and it's the refill
to his ink pen
and he had way underestimated and
stepped way too close you realized
suddenly and when that moment happened
to him you saw him holding his pen with
one hand and his refill with the other
and he was just looking and he's stunned
he's in this cycle of trying to make
that because the only solution it could
be is the one he didn't want to accept
right so he's canceled out the truth so
where is he going to go from there yeah
that I had stolen it taken apart put it
back together and put it back on him
couldn't be that so what else could it
be mhm pausing Time time travel yeah so
in that now at that moment while he's in
that bewildered State I just said well
at least you didn't lose your money or
your wallet and when I did that I just
glanced down because I noticed he has
watch on his left wrist so he's probably
right-handed so he's probably going to
keep his wallet in his back right so I
just glanced back toward his back right
pocket and he jumped on that big he
reached him pulled out his wallet real
quick checked to see if he had
everything still in his wallet and I
laughed I saw his attention shift back
to the pen and I pushed down his hand I
said you still have everything and he
put it away and he says you've got to do
this to Lisa I said yeah great to meet
her I just looked over his shoulder to
where I thought Lisa might be and he
took off to go get Lisa comes back and
he shoves this lady towards me and this
agent and I'm dance monkey dance yeah I
have a I'm having well I'm there to
perform but no I know I know and I'm
talking to the agent I have a drink and
this is an important thing the drink
because it's a part of the style and
it's not alcohol it's just water but I
don't need anything from him I'm not
being inv validated and a lot of
performers will try to spoon feed the
audience but it's letting them bring a
thing to them letting them have a
reaction without you needing to feed
back off of it and letting people have
this experience for themselves and so
when he pushed the lady up I I didn't
quite look at at first I said sorry it's
nice to meet you I looked over and I
said what was your name she goes Lisa
and she hadn't quite come close to me at
all I said she said what's happening I
said sorry Lisa he wants me to steal
something from you she says what I said
do you like chocolate she says chocolate
I said yes there's some chocolate in
your purse she said what she opens her
purse and she finds a bag of M&M's in
her purse and he's reacting very
strongly to this and he's watching this
third party he thinks and then she said
how did those get on my purse I said the
same way Jamal's driver's license got to
out of his wallet now he's jumped back
into the equation he rips his wallet out
again realiz his license is missing and
he goes where in the is my driver's
license and I said it's in the chocolate
as I take a sip of my water I just walk
away so I let them piece it together
themselves she tears over the M&M's and
she finds a license in her
thing